[Music]
good afternoon thank you for being with
here with me this afternoon for this
important update
i want to note up front that my remarks
today may be a little bit longer than
normal
i want to be clear and fully lay out for
you the situation our state is now
facing we are at a critical point
and i want all nevadans to understand
why
i wanted to start by highlighting some
encouraging news
on the vaccine front on friday night
the fda granted emergency use
authorization
of the pfizer vaccine and this morning
western states panel tasked with
reviewing the vaccine
signed off as well we anticipate
receiving the first shipment in the
state on monday
and the state team has worked closely
with our partners
and plans are in place to distribute the
first allocation
of the pfizer vaccine to our front-line
health care workers
for immediate vaccination and staff and
residents in our nursing skilled
facilities
as soon as possible i know last week our
state team did a test run
of the distribution process with the
people who will be responsible for
transporting the actual vaccines
across the state to the practice run to
make sure
everything goes smoothly as new
developments on the vaccine and the
vaccination process unfold
we will work to keep nevadans posted on
any updates
and news as they become available
as you all know dr fauci predicted that
thanksgiving would cause a surge on top
of a surge
we have every indication that's where
the nation
and where nevada is headed at this time
according to state health officials we
are just now beginning to see the
effects of the holiday
in our current data as we expected
what appeared to be a brief decline in
new cases over the holiday
was related to decreased testing over
the holiday
it certainly was not because covid was
magically
gone we continue to see an increase in
hospitalization statewide
with almost 1700 nevadans in the
hospital battling covin
as of friday while rural and northern
nevada
are still experiencing very high levels
of cobit hospitalization
declines are beginning to be noticeable
in southern nevada hospitalizations have
yet to peak
as the area remains in the midst of
their third hospitalization wave
as you well know helping to protect our
health care
infrastructure has been one of their
main goals
in our response efforts i want every
nevadan to have access to care
and our health care workers have done
everything in their power
including setting up hospitals in
parking garages
to make sure that they are there for you
when you need it
whether you have a heart attack your
braking arm
or you catch the flu there is no doubt
our hospitals are feeling an increased
strain
due to an increase in covid patients and
our health care workers are too
they need your help they deserve your
thanks
most concerningly covet deaths are on
the rise
we have now lost 2539 nevadans to this
virus
2539 nevadans
as you know almost three weeks ago
nevada entered a statewide pause
in the face of increasing covert cases
hospitalizations
and deaths this statewide pause
implemented incredibly strict mitigation
measures in an effort to protect both
lives and protect our fragile economy
under this pause capacity is limited to
25 percent at many businesses
including our restaurants bars casino
floors
and gyms additionally
public gatherings are capped at 50
individuals or 25
capacity whichever is less and private
residential gatherings are limited to 10
people
maximum from no more than two households
i spoke recently about how we must
create a bridge between our current
situation
and when the covet 19 vaccines become
widely available
you all know the tools to get us across
the bridge
avoid gatherings limit exposure by
staying home as much as you can
wash your hands wear your mask
in fact in a report from ihme at the
university of washington
they estimated that as of november 30th
74 of nevadans always were a mask when
leaving their home
more importantly the report noted that
if we got that number to 95 percent
compliance
we could potentially save a thousand
lives by april first
i know the mitigation restrictions in
place under the current pause
are devastating to many nevadans who
just want to go back to normal
who are worried about their jobs their
businesses
keeping their homes getting the kids
back in school
but as i've said for nine months now we
must do what we can to protect the
health and safety of the public
that remains more important than ever as
we experience these record numbers
that's why today i am announcing that we
will be extending the restrictions in
the pause
under the current pop in place under the
current pause
in nevada for the next month through
january 15th
we will be extending the restrictions in
the current pause
through january 15th as always we will
be monitoring and evaluating our current
situation
day to day and week by week we'll remain
under the current restrictions for now
with the goal of getting through the
next month due to the reasons i'll
outline in a moment
but i need to be clear if officials and
experts agree that our trends are going
beyond our ability to respond
i will be forced to come in front of you
all again with tougher actions
i believe we can avoid those actions if
we all commit to it
and before i outline the reasons behind
this choice i'd like to announce one
more public health mitigation measure
something that will greatly assist in
keeping nevadans in the safest place
they can be
in their homes tomorrow i will sign a
directive that will place a moratorium
on most residential evictions in nevada
with the effective date and time of 1201
am
on december 15th originally put a
residential eviction moratorium in place
early stages of the pandemic in
conjunction with the stay-at-home order
keeping the vans in their homes to slow
covet 19
was safer then than making emergency
shelter
housing or shelter arrangements
which increases the risk of spreading
covet 19 for them
that still remains true today we
transitioned out of the moratorium as
numbers improved
and as tenant assistant programs came
online
however as we are now in the depths of
our most significant and dangerous surge
of this crisis and with an impending
deadline
to be able to use federal assistance for
tenants
i must reinstate a moratorium to ensure
the vans can stay in their
homes during this critical phase of the
pandemic
when people are evicted it is impossible
to stay home
they are out looking for jobs and
housing to desperately save their
families
they will spread 19 unintentionally
because they have no options the cdc and
state public health officials
have expressed concern over families and
individuals
that are being evicted in fact my covet
19 medical advisory team
has formally recommended reinstatement
of an eviction moratorium to reduce
increased community transmission that is
caused by displacement and homelessness
in nevada according to our state health
officials when people are evicted
they're at a higher risk of getting
kobit 19 as
families may be forced to share a
smaller space or live in crowded
shelters
local officials are also concerned with
the possibility
of our shelters and other congregate
housing options
being overrun with homeless families
this is a reality we cannot afford to
risk at this time
during this current surge we are
experiencing it is critical
that we do all we can to keep nevadans
in their homes
and mitigate the risk of spread and
infection
as i have been clear from the start this
moratorium
does not repeat it does not relieve
renters
from their obligation to pay rent to
their landlords
the state has already created and
provided lease addendums
where landlords and tenants can work on
repayment solutions
together the moratorium will apply to
all
tenants unable to pay rent and will
extend through march
31st it will not prohibit certain
evictions
including for example lease breaches for
things like unlawful activity
or nuisance we also have rental
assistance programs up and running
throughout the state so renters can have
some of their outstanding rent for 2020
paid
however these programs are supported
with federal assistance dollars
that currently expire at the end of
december that's this month
and we need to ensure that there are
protections for tenants going forward
i recognize that this extension will be
economically hard
on some of our landlords i know i've
asked landlords to sacrifice during this
pandemic
now i'm asking you to again do more
for a few months so that we can push
through what i hope is the last
surge of this virus i will do everything
i can do
to continue to push for economic
assistance
for impacted landlords this is one of
dozens of areas of economic assistance
that we are hopeful that the federal
government will help provide
with the extension of this pause the
evictions moratorium
the cooperation of nevadans and a
vaccine on the horizon
i am hopeful we can continue to stand
together in this fight
against the virus we are fighting the
virus
we cannot fight one another there isn't
a day that goes by when i don't think
about the great balancing act that
nevada faces
and i know how the how the tightrope
that we must walk is more pronounced
here than in any other state
due to our economic structure
i want you to know that i see what you
see
on one hand we have record cases in our
hospitals are under increased strain due
to covet
on the other hand our families are
suffering economically
with unemployment rate remaining in the
top two highest in the country
and little remaining assistance
available
some say we've gone too far some say we
aren't doing enough
i understand both sides the last nine
months have been full of decisions
with no winning options leaving us to
determine which choice would lessen
the blow the most i know that
and you all know that but early last
week i received a report from the white
house covent task force
which included recommendations for
mitigating the spread
it became clear to me that the federal
government has
yet to grasp what is so evident to all
of us here of in nevada
about the complexities of our current
situation
one of their recommendations said this
despite the severity of this surge and
the threat to the hospital systems
many state and local governments are not
implementing the same mitigation
policies
that stem the tie that must happen now
that is a very stark departure from
their message and actions over the last
nine months
that contradicted and undermined
recommended mitigation measures
touted by respected public health
officials throughout the country
but nonetheless i agree with them the
problem we have is the mitigation policy
that most successfully stem the tide in
nevada
was our complete shutdown for the white
house and feds to send that
recommendation without including
a big check for nevadans a plan for
providing our state with funding
to give our families a safety net in
this time of great
tribulation is downright out of touch
and offensive
a shutdown is unrealistic without
additional support
and i realize i owe to all those in the
bands who may be monitoring our cover
trends right now
and wondering why i don't move in that
direction so let me explain
i've said repeatedly that we are trying
desperately
to balance public health and the impacts
to our economy
but i want to be clear about what i mean
when i say economy
what i mean is impacts to our families
their ability to feed themselves and
their kids
to keep the lights up to keep a roof
over their heads
to earn a paycheck and keep their
benefits that allows them access to
healthcare
and right now our families in countless
nevadans are teetering on the brink
in our first months of the pandemic
nevada lost
250 000 jobs a quarter of a million jobs
reaching an unemployment rate of 30.1
the highest level ever reported by any
state in modern history
for reference during the great recession
nevada lost approximately 180 000
jobs over nearly three years
unemployment benefits are established
for a full year
and due to the pandemic nearly 142 000
events
have completely exhausted that
eligibility with the vast majority
unable to file again until mid-march
2021 or later
let me repeat that without additional
federal assistance
the majority of these 142 000 nevadans
will have no further unemployment
benefits available to them
from the state or federal government to
support their lost income
this is a stark difference from the
spring when the additional assistance of
the federal government
helped many of nevada's most vulnerable
workers displaced by covid
receive unemployment unemployment
benefits that replaced roughly 100
of their lost income that reality no
longer exists
in the spring at the time nevada and
states across the country were under
state home orders
many individuals families and businesses
had savings accounts that helped them
hold on
and help them hold over the state of
nevada had a savings account too
our rainy day fund we had just received
robust federal support that provided
income replacement to individuals
and gave state and local governments
funding to provide a safety net
as of today none of those things exist
personal savings accounts have been
depleted the state emptied its rainy day
fund in the spring to address our
massive budget deficit
the funding we received from the federal
cares act is set to expire at the end of
this year
being the programs created by state
local governments to assist the veterans
directly
will have to stop in a couple of weeks
according to one of our state economists
to return to full stay-at-home
restrictions
without the savings and assistance we
had in the spring
would put us in a position that would be
as bad or worse
than the great depression that means
return to historic unemployment numbers
and a significant demand for public
assistance with no
funds to pay for it if we could write a
check to every nevadan right now
to provide them the ability to stay home
and stop the spread
i'd do it but we can't now i want to
talk bluntly about gaming and
hospitality for a minute
i know it's hard for nevadans to
reconcile while some areas of our
economy and public life are restricted
while the state's casinos are open i get
why it's hard to reconcile that fact
and i want to talk honestly with you the
gaming industry
is under the same restrictions as many
of our small businesses
and in some cases even tougher
restrictions
restaurants and bars and casinos face
the same capacity limits
as those in our neighborhoods gaming
floors have been reduced to 25
capacity as well in fact under the
authority of the gaming control board
the gaming industry is arguably the most
regulated industry in the state
they hold privileged licenses they must
follow
strict mitigation directives and face
tough consequences
if they don't and i think it's important
to make this a hundred percent clear
when i think of the gaming industry i'm
not losing sleep at night because i'm
worried about their stock prices
or whether gaming executives are going
to make it through the pandemic and be
able to keep a roof over their heads
i lose sleep at night because when we
were under a stay-at-home order in the
spring
we lost a quarter of a million jobs in
three months in the state
and that's largely due to casinos being
closed for 78
days straight i'm thinking of our
blackjack dealers
our cooks our valet drivers our
housekeepers
and our performers they're what makes
our amazing hospitality industry which
makes up one of the largest shares of
workers in our state
that's why i worked with our legislature
our employers
our labor unions and workers the past
the strongest hospitality coveted
protection
in the nation these are the folks we're
fighting to protect
it's the hundreds of thousands of
nevadans who take pride
they take pride in showing up every day
for work
and their ability to give them to
provide for their families
if we take that away the bottom falls
out for our entire state
the numbers i walked through a moment
ago prove that
and here's why else gaming matters of
this state and what the white house
doesn't seem to understand
if this has to shut down again the state
loses an estimated
52 million dollars in gaming tax revenue
a month
52 million a month in tax revenue that
doesn't include
room taxes live entertainment taxes and
more
and when i say revenue i mean the money
that the state has to give
to use for direct assistance to defends
in the form of schools
public and mental health food banks and
more
it helps fund the critical services we
rely on the safety net nevadans need
that's why it is devastated through this
pandemic
i want to remind you all when i first
entered office and put together a budget
for 2019 legislative session
that was our first time in 10 years that
our state recovered
their state budget reflected recovery
from the great recession
it took 10 years for the state and
nevadans to claw back from that
i am so grateful to our former governor
brian sandoval
nolan nevada residents who worked so
hard during this time to get us there
because of that 10-year recovery i was
able to include the largest amount of
funding for mental health services in
the state's history
among other achievements but it took 10
years
and here we are now at another
inflection point
i certainly don't want to lose another
10 years or more trying to claw back
where we were
prior to the pandemic so when i talk to
you about what the state is going to do
and about revenue and about unemployment
our safety
it is not lost on me that decisions we
make today
and how we handle this balancing act
right now will have generational impacts
the decisions i make and all of you make
in the coming months will determine how
we're going to recover
over the next decade or more and this
balancing act includes factors that too
often get lost in the larger debate
but are just as important to consider
it's always things that we don't always
hear about
this week it was reported that nevada
has seen a 50 percent
increase in opioid and fentanyl involved
drug
overdose deaths from the first quarter
to the second quarter of 2020
that's startling and i don't think it's
a coincidence
that it's happening in the middle of
this pandemic i could go on
and on and i know you could too
prioritizing
prioritizing our economy or our health
is a false choice
for our state if you don't have a job
you can't provide for your family if you
lose your home
if the state has no safety net to help
people will not be healthy
these aren't binary choices this is
incredibly complex
and i think about it every day i have
never and never
will deny the severity of this virus
this fire has posed a threat
unlike anything we have seen before and
for the last nine months i've
consistently explained the risk we are
under
i've relied on the science i've listened
to public health officials
like many other nevadans i wake up in
the morning
thinking about covet 19 it's the last
thing i think about at night
it is constantly on my mind
the loss of life is devastating so many
families have been forever changed
because terrible impacts of this virus
the stress on our health care workers is
unbearable
they've continued to show up every day
in these trying situations
to help their fellow nevadans so when i
read the white house reports that say
states and local governments aren't
doing enough
you can imagine how my blood boils
more than nine months ago the federal
government handed the state's
responsibility of dealing with this
global pandemic
they told the states to deal with it so
we did we have navigated this pandemic
through strong
state to state partnerships through
shared sacrifice
and through the grit and perseverance of
our communities
you all stepped up including the private
sector task force
who secured millions of masks gloves
gowns and tests using their
international relationships
and supply chains because we weren't
getting enough from this life-saving
resources from washington dc
for nine months the state has been on
the front line of this war against covet
and for nine months we've heard that
reinforcements and air cover
are on the way just hang in there we
don't see any planes flying overhead
instead every day i wake up to a new
headline
about those in charge in washington dc
aren't able to compromise on getting
desperately needed funds
to states because republicans on
business liability
and democrats want direct and flexible
funding to state and local governments
i don't understand why there's a general
philosophical objection to funding state
and local governments
because again this money goes out
directly to those who are suffering
and if senator mcconnell doesn't think
people need assistance
he has an open invitation for me to come
to nevada anytime
to walk through the halls of our
hospital coveted units visit a homeless
shelter
that's full of families at a home that
had a home just a month ago
when he opposes money for state and
local governments he opposes money for
food
for unemployment for health care if
washington dc
needs some guidance on how to reach a
compromise look no further than nevada
nevada managed to pass a business
liability
and worker safety protection program
this summer with support of both parties
we did it with workers labor unions
major employers and government officials
all coming to the virtual table both
sides knew we might not love everything
in here but we all said
we're going to do this because we're
going to protect nevada in this moment
it's not easy compromise often seems to
be the hardest path
but we prove it's possible if you throw
the politics to the side
and prioritize people i hope and pray
that congress listens to us and our
federal delegation who are fighting for
more funding for our state
but if we've learned anything over the
last nine months
said we have to figure out how to get
through this on our own
if we don't then we lead to further
restrictions that decimate
our economy for generations or we
continue
the down this path of massive loss of
public health
there's some hope on the horizon as i
mentioned earlier
we know the vaccine is on the way
there's always some hope that we could
get additional funding from the federal
government
but as of right now neither of those
things
exist so in the absence of this
leadership and support
i have made the best decision for our
state and the continuation of the
current restrictions implemented during
this pause
i believe that we can all work together
to make sure we maximize the benefits of
these mitigation measures
and they call upon all of you to join in
helping our state make it through this
i don't say this is a threat but it's a
reflection of the precarious position
we're in at this time
if we cannot work together to bring
these numbers under control over the
next month
i will be forced to come before you
again with tougher actions
so in this moment amidst the dire
economic situation
the surge of the virus we all remain on
the front lines of this battle
tired worn out wanting to throw in a
towel
we have a choice we can look to our
neighbors
to the left and to the right and say
every man and woman
for themselves or we can look at our
fellow nevadas and say
i'm going to have your back and know
that you'll have mine
we are all we have at this moment if we
want to avoid another great depression
avoid preventable deaths and stop the
overwhelming of our hospitals
while our health care workers are
literally crying for help
that we will rise to this occasion and
fight
a lot of folks have been talking about
the american people that we don't look
out for one another
that some like some other countries do
i'm going to wholeheartedly reject that
today for the state of nevada
i refuse to believe what they're saying
about americans and about nevadans
i refuse to believe that we do not love
our neighbors
as we love ourselves i refuse to believe
that we do not care about the poor among
us
i refuse to believe that we cannot live
in harmony with one another
some nevadans have been affected by the
virus more than others
and others have faced economic
challenges brought on by this pandemic
no matter challenges we are facing
individually
we face them all together and
collectively as nevadans
nevada will make it through this and how
well we do will be determined
by how much we care for one another
especially those who are the hardest hit
we have to keep fighting to get this
under control
we get to the media question and answer
session i just wanted to note
according to our latest statistics
nevadan is testing positive for coving
every 40 seconds
that's 45 cases in 30 minutes
approximately the time frame i've been
speaking to you
and every hour and 15 minutes nevadan
dies from coven
the viruses still prevalent in our
communities
please protect yourselves and one
another by continuing to wear your mask
wash your hands frequently and practice
social distancing
together we can help stand the tide
god bless you all i think my staff will
now help facilitate some
questions and answers with members of
the media on the call megan are you
there
yes governor thank you again if we could
uh utilize the raise hand
function on zoom and if we could keep
our cameras off for the whole time
i'll call on you and you should be able
to unmute yourself we'll go to megan
messerly of the nevada independent for
the first question
megan hi governor thanks for doing this
i just wanted to ask with the holidays
coming up is it safe for people to
travel to nevada
over the holidays including to las vegas
for new year's eve
why or why not well we have the same
restrictions and people
in place for people that are traveling
to nevada over the holiday over the
holiday period
that they practice our protocols that
they respect our protocols that they
were a mask
that they practice social distancing
that they avoid large gatherings
if they do so we feel that everybody can
be safe if they don't want to follow
those protocols
and they refuse to be part of the
solution then they should probably stay
home
safety is a partnership with us with our
resort community
and with our visitors we need everybody
to do their part
thank you megan thank you governor we'll
go to colton lockout of the las vegas
review journal for the next question
colton hey governor can you hear me
[Music]
oh governor hello we can hear you colton
go ahead all right
so we've been under the pause for about
three weeks now uh
do you and your team believe that the
current mitigation measures are working
to slow the spread given the
continued spread of the virus increased
in deaths hospitalizations and other
metrics
i apologize when i didn't hear the first
part of your your question could you ask
me one more time
yes we've been under the pause for about
three weeks now uh with these current
stricter measures
do you and your team believe that these
current mitigation measures are working
to slow the spread
given the metrics that we're seeing in
that time obviously we've seen numbers
increase over this time but i do feel
that the mitigation measures are are
working i mean but for these
uh measures that we've got i think our
numbers would be a lot higher
than they currently are the majority of
nevadans
are practicing other protocols they're
wearing a mask they're
practicing social distancing but as a
study at the university of washington
showed
if we could go from 74 compliance to 95
compliance we'd save a thousand lives
between now and april
that would affect a lot of families so
they're working but we need more of it
thank you colton thank you governor
we'll go to the next question and
madison
i believe the last name is mckay madison
hi gov governor thank you so much for
your time um now that the pause is being
extended until january is there anything
you have to say to businesses that are
struggling right now any support from
ear end
despite you know the lack of federal
assistance right now
well you know i understand how
businesses feel we're doing everything
we can to protect the businesses and to
protect the customers of those
businesses
and i encourage them to contact uh our
delegation is working to help us with
the federal
assistance but we have to do what we can
safety is a priority for all of us
that's what we're focusing on we're
hopeful
that you know this extension will will
get us where we need to go with the
combination of the extension
the protocols that are still in place
and the vaccines that are coming
we're hopeful we'll be in a better place
by the time this would expire
thank you madison and thank you governor
we'll go to brian hoffman from ktvn for
the next question brian
hey thank you so much so i got a
two-part question for you
one when uh that uh pause does expire
what type of regulations could we
possibly be looking at
and have you reached out or spoken with
the incoming uh
president of joe biden about receiving
possible
uh expanded federal assistance
let me get into the hypotheticals about
you know what we could put into place
uh after the end of the third
one month extension of the pause that
will depend on our numbers at the time
and what the situation is uh as it
relates to the vice president
and uh our vice president-elect
biden and uh pamela harris we have been
in discussion with their teams they
understand
the difficulty that we're facing but
you've got to understand
they're going to be off in office for
five weeks that's a long time from now
that we have to hang on for and we need
something done
and we need something done now it's an
open invitation to anybody that doesn't
think there's a need to come on out here
and i'll take you through our hospitals
in our businesses that are suffering
and our schools where we still don't
have kids in the classrooms to show that
the need is real
thank you governor and thank you for the
question we'll go um i believe it's jay
jones
that says jace galaxy s10 but i believe
it's jay jones from the los
angeles times yes good afternoon can you
hear me governor
uh yeah i'm trying go ahead okay thank
you
oh first of all happy holidays to you
and yours um
with christmas less than two weeks away
no public official wants to be a scrooge
throwing more people out of work and
increasing the
financial pain here in our state but
that said last week the daily number of
new covet cases in clark county nevada
per capita was higher than the number in
los angeles county california
which is in a much stricter lockdown
situation over
ordered by governor newsome i understand
you're on a tightrope as you described
earlier this afternoon but
given nevada's code numbers and the
soaring volume
doesn't public health outweigh
the certainly understandable economic
impact
well public health includes a lot of
things it certainly includes a cova
diagnosis but includes the mental health
that people are facing
the homelessness that they're facing the
food
shortages that they're facing we're in a
unique position in nevada we're relying
on one
industry our hospitality and tourism
industry we don't have
the i.t industry we don't have
manufacturing in southern nevada
you know we don't have a diversified
economy like other states do our economy
is basically reliant
on hospitality and people coming here to
have a good time and enjoy themselves
and when you talk about the health
crisis that it could provide
you've got to balance the health crisis
as it relates to kova diagnosis
with as i said the use of opioids and
fentanyl deaths have increased 50
percent
quarter over quarter and some of that
has to be attributed to the lockdown
situation and the restrictions that are
in place so
we're trying to take all of those
criterion statistics into account when
we come up with the plan
thank you governor thank you jay for the
question um we have time for a few more
i am monitoring both the chat and the
raised hand function
so we'll go to astrid mendez with
channel 13 next astrid
hi good afternoon everyone as it was
mentioned
christmas is about to be happening and
even though with the moratorium we know
that some families have been
getting those notices that they need to
make it as soon as possible
obviously one thing that you just
mentioned right now is that
it's important for families to stay
together and to stay inside to avoid
more copic cases
what should families do or who should
they talk to or
contact in case that they're still faced
with an eviction inc
even with the extension and the
reinstatement of the moratorium that you
just basically announced
well you're right the the eviction
moratorium will be signed tomorrow
details will be coming with the mortar
with the directive that we signed
tomorrow and will provide instruction
in terms of what they should do when you
talk about christmas being two weeks
away i want to add a little something
you're right christmas is less than two
weeks away
and the best gift you can give your
family
is their health and we can all give each
other a gift of health by practicing
these protocols
by wearing the mask by avoiding large
gatherings
by washing your hands and to say look
this year we're not going to be able to
get together for that big christmas
dinner
and i'm giving you the gift we're going
to make it next year we're going to all
make it through this
together and next year we'll be able to
get together for christmas dinner
so that's the best gift that you can
give your family and your friends
thank you governor we'll go to howard
from cdc gaming howard
governor how you doing today thanks for
the conference call thanks for the
presser
um you i took what you said about the
gaming industry and you know not shut
not closing the casinos
the heart i i guess the question is did
you have you had discussions with the
you know different operators the casino
leaders about this and you know you see
what's happening that a lot of
properties are shutting down
um hotels midweek or restaurants they're
they're rolling back on their own
they're not waiting for um like in
pennsylvania or illinois or um
ohio you know other states that have
closed down so obviously you didn't want
to close down you're kind of leaving it
up to the
seems to be leading up to the operators
to make these decisions
each of the operators make their own
decisions and they're governed by the
game and control board who have total
confidence in
uh in terms of providing us with
restrictions and criteria for them to
operate under
every state is different again you have
to understand that nevada this is our
only uh big industry that we have in
southern nevada so
it's incumbent upon us to do what we can
to protect them
i'm thinking of the hundreds of
thousands of employees
that work in these properties that are
affected by this as i said i don't
i'm not concerned about the stock price
of you know some of these properties i'm
concerned about how the
individual employees are impacted and
affected
by the virus and by the shutting down of
the strip
thank you governor thank you howard for
the question we will go to
david from eight news now david
governor i hope you can hear me there um
thank you for taking my question my
question is about
the vaccine and how to uh how we're
moving forward that
with that obviously it's long awaited
we've heard a lot from state officials
about the
tiers one two and three i'm curious
though what you had to say
for the majority of us who are in that
final tier who are going to have to hold
out
until we get a large amount of the
vaccine to come you know in the spring
and what your message is for for the
majority of us
who won't be vaccinated right away well
my message to the majority of people
that won't be receiving it
and uh and it's unfortunate we can't get
more and we're doing everything we can
as a state to
increase our allocation as you get our
allocation up is that
continue to protect yourself by
practicing the protocols
if you wear a mask you wash your hands
you practice social distancing you avoid
large groups you're going to be in a
safer position
and as more and more people get
vaccinated they'll be
less likely of exposure that you will be
receiving as a result of others being
vaccinated but
it's going to take some time for the
state of nevada for the
entire country to get a vaccine and we
need to be as patient as we can along
the way
uh there's hope that this week the fda
is looking at moderna which is going to
be more vaccines that they're going to
be providing
and we would be getting our share of
those too and we're hopeful that we'll
get as many as possible in the weeks and
months ahead
but for those who are later along the
tiers in terms of getting the vaccine
continue to practice the protocols that
we've put in place
thank you governor thank you david for
the question we have time for a couple
more we'll go to lauren clark from
channel three
lauren you're up next hi there governor
thank you so much for
the time my question is also vaccine
related
as you know there's still some people
who don't necessarily have full trust in
this vaccine right now
will your office be doing anything in
terms of education encouraging people to
go out and get it
we will be doing as much as we possibly
can with our medical facilities
with our doctors on the front line in
terms of describing just how safe this
vaccine is
i mean it's been thoroughly vetted our
western states have edited a second time
they've approved it the vaccine should
be here tomorrow
and i would have no problem whether it
would be my mother
my sister my kids my wife anyone getting
the vaccine i'm confident
in the safety and the efficacy of the
vaccines
it would encourage people to take part
and receive the vaccine
thank you governor thank you we'll do
the last question from sam metz if we
weren't able to grab your question today
please feel free to send me an email or
a text
after this so we'll do um sam metz from
the ap
um to go next and ask mendez if you
don't mind just keeping your camera off
sam go ahead and ask your question hi
governor thanks for doing this
when you talk about a bridge how long do
you anticipate the bridge being
i assume we don't know exactly but
should businesses and residents assume
that the bridge
with all the restrictions it entails
lasts until mid-summer when the
vaccine's widely distributed
until mid-summer sam but you've got to
understand when this started back in
march
and i made the decision that we had to
shut down you know our casinos and our
businesses and our schools
i never thought that we would be here
nine months later
facing a lot of the same problems in the
situation that we have
it is my hope that uh as people continue
to follow the protocols that we put in
place
that they wear a mask that they wash our
hands that they practice social
distancing they avoid large groups
they help us protect from any surges
coming from
christmas or new year's that we'll be
able to keep our numbers low and let the
health care system catch up
when you couple that with the fact that
vaccines are here
tomorrow or tuesday and we'll start
vaccinating people
and that they will then be uh immune
hopefully
after the second vaccine from from the
virus that you know less people will be
potential carriers if we can get these
numbers down but
as i said last time i had you all
together
we're much closer to the end of this
pandemic than we are to the beginning
and i still feel that way today we are
closer to the end
than we are in the beginning and there
are there's hope on the horizon
but if we work together what i said i
believe
i don't believe what you hear out there
i believe that nevadans care
about their neighbors like they care
about themselves i believe that nevada
cares
about our homeless population and
believe nevadans care
about those that are less fortunate we
need to practice that as we move forward
and hopefully
when i see you next time in the middle
of january if not before we'll be able
to
have some positive more positive news
coming your way